Let's go to our caller from the six to six
area code.
Who's calling today from six to six.
Hello? Yes, that's you.
Yeah.
Hello Dave.
My name is Steve.
I'm from Azusa.
Hey, Steve.
California.
Yeah, I'm a new listener on my question.
I have a couple of them basically would descend
it being the way they are.
Even with this impeachment going to that point,
they're not gonna vote for it.
So I mean isn't this basically just an election
type of move Democrat?
And why don't the Democrats play a little
bit tougher?
I mean I was just watching on MSNBC and CNN
how Trump has just got so much bad stuff in
this past.
But hold on a second, let's, let's go through
this.
Let's, let's think this through Steve.
When you say why can't Democrats be tougher?
What do you mean?
What do you want them to do?
Oh no, no, I don't want him to do anything.
I'm just saying he is so just outright dirty
about everything.
Lying and everything.
And why don't the Democrats like, but they
don't have to lie but they need to expose
these lies and play on the more.
So just giving a little bit of air time and
then letting it go.
Listen,
I don't, I don't agree with you in the sense
that just pointing out that Donald Trump lies
has not been very effective because Donald
Trump has pre emptied a lot of that by saying
it's all fake news.
He's done a really good job of that.
So whenever we say, Hey look, here's five
things Trump lied about, his supporters don't
care.
So my hope is that the impeachment inquiry,
if it's carried out correctly, will expose
the country not to Trump lied cause he lies
all the time and that that's not moving the
needle.
But this isn't, this is a person who is a
systemic danger to the country and you should
vote for someone else in November of 2020
that's the hope.
I don't know that it will happen.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
I'm, I'm hoping it just seems that they're
just so blind.
The people on the right that this is, this
is so ridiculous.
I can't, I couldn't believe another four years
if it does happen.
Yup.
And it may, well it may well, sadly Steve,
Oh boy.
Hey, the other thing, David, what do you think
about climate change?
And the way that we're racing towards the
extinction.
And it's almost as if, once again, fossil
fuels, I mean they kill so many people, just
all these different things that are bad and
yet they're getting pushed forward and the
things they're just saying all costs too much
to do this costume.
Yeah, I mean there's a lot of different questions
in there, but you know, this is obviously
one of the foremost, this is one of the top
three issues of our time and uh, you know,
we've talked a lot about it and it's extraordinarily
disheartening what's going on.
Steve, great to hear from you.
I hope to hear from you again.
Let me take a quick break, but if you're holding
on to talk to me,
don't hang up because I will go right back
to the phones after this.